what's your why hey if I don't get y'all
nothing else you better start that
what's your why you know why I do what I
do when I do it so passionate cuz my
grandfather was a high school dropout my
father was a high school dropout I was a
high school dropout and we bout to break
the cycle I do what I do so my son won't
have to go through what I went through I
do what I do because my daughter says
she going to Harvard
what sure why why do you wake up in the
morning why do you put on that Jersey
why don't you go out and practice why I
have boundaries so just because it's my
company and doesn't mean I can take
calls all day right I have boundaries so
you can't call me in a certain time why
I'm working so I'm on the phone all day
and I'm saying it's the entrepreneur
because one of the gaps with
entrepreneurs is that they feel like
because they own their day they can
spend it like they want you cannot spend
it like you want to you so if you were
working for IBM or you're working for
for where are you working for you could
be on the phone all day at a major
corporation talking on the phone so so
why do you allow yourself to talk on the
phone when is your business one of my
rituals is when I fix party there are no
interruptions when I get started I don't
care if it's my wife my children they
know that from a certain timeframe I'm
going all in and I can't go all in
answer the phone I can't go all in
watching TV in distress I can't go in
with the distraction and so some
entrepreneurs are like why am I not
blowing up you don't have that that that
moment of your day I don't care if it's
two hours four hours where you shut the
entire world out no Twitter no Facebook
no you know no Instagram no we love
Instagram we love that as you know your
content probably would be stronger if
you had that that time of isolation of
solitude where you give yourself a
chance to think you give yourself a
chance to go in and when you go in you
go 120 percent you just watch two
amazing clip some Eric Thomas take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]